some brand new calls to censor
conservatives as republicans plot
payback
against big tech axios reporting some
gop lawmakers are working on ways
to fight back after top conservatives
were silenced that comes as parlor gets
back online after getting taken down
by amazon the company's ceo says he
hopes to be back up and running
at the end of the month but that is
small victory for parlor that small
victory excuse me for parlor
is not stopping others for calling for a
crackdown on free speech
a former top facebook official is
arguing more conservative content
should be erased we have to turn down
the capability of these conservative
influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example that have
a larger daytime a larger audience than
daytime cnn
and they are extremely radical and
pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes
in particular to think about whether or
not they want to be effectively cable
networks for disinformation
and former national security expert
claiming some followers of conservative
media are being
radicalized like isis while katie kirk
says gop lawmakers need to be
deprogrammed much after president trump
left twitter the decline in extremist
content is really critical people talk
about political
sort of debate in this country this is
propaganda
the same kind that isis used and the
decline of that is really important
i mean it's really bizarre isn't it when
you think about
how awol so many of these members of
congress have gotten
but i also think some of them are
believing the garbage that they are
being fed
the question is how are we going to
really almost deprogram these people who
have signed up
for the cult of trump greg gutfeld i'm
assuming
that you have some thoughts we've all
missed you welcome back
over to you well first off facebook i
remember the good old days when facebook
was so honorable and noble
when they were raiding girls faces
remember that
they were such a good company that's
what that company's based on
so save their uh save their noble
beliefs and and political by the way the
best thing about facebook
are the are the politics because it's so
funny everything else about facebook is
terrible
okay so the katie couric she says people
need to be
deprogrammed which is a great word from
somebody
who is literally a programmer right
she hosts hosted programs so she was the
shaper of narratives
and story lines and packaged her own
assumptions
that she shared with other people in
these elite power groups in the media
so when a programmer runs into a counter
programmer
what do they do they say oh we must
de-program them
because they're not part of our group so
their solution these
gated protected programmers in the media
in academia
and culture is to de-platform the
threats
which is uh like you see cnn talking
about fox news how uh should they be on
tv should oan be on tv should uh newsmax
be on tv
they're gonna try to d platform anybody
different from them whether it's
websites people or networks
and this is gonna this is gonna drive
people further underground
it's just like kicking an already angry
dog and
lastly we gotta look at the unity the
unified aspect of this
cnn trying to ban competitors publishing
companies
and music labels uh dropping artists
corporations severing ties to
politicians
the vetting of the national guard the
demand to revoke diplomas
going after i don't know banks and
financial institutions
so every major institution in this media
academic
industrial complex are joining hands and
they're closing the gates
and they're creating one singular chorus
to destroy you
in such a relaxed way because they know
they can get away with it
but it's not gonna go this this is not
gonna cure anything it's just gonna make
people angrier
juan when we talk about uh parlor and
they're gonna i guess
coming back online that's what their ceo
said um
you know the part of the thing one of
the things that the companies have
pointed to is that there was violent
rhetoric or
threats even um but also in the
reporting since january 6 and the
attack on the capital it showed that um
there was a lot of planning
uh for that that happened on facebook
and it happened on twitter but
yet that those you know platforms did
not get
taken off what do you think of that
no i think that clearly parlor was
intended as an alternative site
but the key to my thinking on this is
that you know this is not about
censoring conservative thought it's
about
doing something about disinformation
outright lies
that led to the violence that we saw at
the capitol
and you know an attack on democracy so i
think all of these sites
are trying to figure out how do you
moderate that kind of
content dana you know to my mind why
haven't the people who said
oh this election was stolen why haven't
they said oh you know we were wrong
we're sorry okay we're wrong you first
they said you know what that was uh
that's a that's a lie and it should
never have been propagated
on american social media because it had
the
impact of promoting that violence it
inspired violence to my mind that
undermined
american democracy and trust in our
institutions trust in the incoming by
the administration
the new yorker has a video out that
shows like bloodthirsty mobs calling for
vice president pence calling for speaker
pelosi
i don't think conservatives i don't
think liberals
want that kind of bloodthirsty action
taking place and if it's linked
to the kind of language and planning
that's taking place over social media
social media
has to respond all right jesse waters
look at your thoughts on that
well i'm taking this very personally
dana because i have a gut feeling
they're going to come after waters world
you do not do that you come after
water's world then gg
shows next then they're coming for the
five even you won
you're right there as a target i don't
have any other skills
if you take me out how am i going to
feed my family
i have to mow lawns like this is the
only really thing i'm proficient in so
you guys
better watch yourselves miranda devine
in the new york post
one of the best newspapers out there i
call it the paper of record
i read her article today and she nails
it she says this is just about
dehumanizing conservatives so you don't
feel
sorry for them when you take away their
rights it's about
eliminating all opposition to biden's
radical agenda because remember chuck
schumer
said he's going to radically transform
america this is about destroying any
resistance to that
so they can't speak up because they're
so intimidated
or they don't even have a platform
democrats are playing for keeps
we want to debate they just want to
censor you
and it's going to backfire as exactly as
gutfeld said because
think about it if you're suspicious
about the election
and then all these powerful interests
align to cancel you
for being suspicious about the election
you're going to be more suspicious
60 percent of the country doesn't trust
the media
that's the latest gallup poll and it's
probably because the media without any
evidence
will call you a gang rapist a white
supremacist or a colluder
but they'll stare at a mountain of
evidence
like hunter biden's laptop before an
election and say
that is a lie so the media needs to look
in
themselves in the mirror and think did i
contribute to any of the distrust
that the american people have in our
institutions because right now it looks
like the corporate media has
lost control of the flow of information
it's going to other platforms and
different voices and instead of
competing with that
they're trying to cancel it and that
makes people even more
distrustful of them emily to jesse's
point about miranda devine
um you know every there are writers and
people that committed violence
but that is not the entire republican
party